[Music]
on this Wednesday night the struggle to
keep up with Canada's cost of living the
inflation rate slightly deflates as food
prices soar everything is up everything
how the low loonies not helping and what
could fuel another spike in gas prices
the investigation into the killing of a
bcrcmp officer she was compassionate and
caring the deadly confrontation and new
murder charge
the prime minister's greenhouse gas
guarantee his promise for 2030.
and a first on the final frontier I feel
very proud to be on aboard the space
station going where no indigenous woman
has gone before
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
soaring inflation has been a significant
Ness to us for millions of Canadians for
months now but tonight there are signs a
situation may be starting to improve
statistics Canada says the annual
inflation rate dropped slightly last
month to 6.9 percent down from 7 percent
in August but food prices were up a
staggering 11.7 percent compared to a
year ago Canadians are paying more for
meat dairy products and fresh vegetables
grocery bills continue to climb at the
fastest rate in more than 40 years all
of this is setting the stage for another
widely expected interest rate hike next
week in our top story tonight Ross Lord
explains how this is impacting Canadians
and when we can expect to see some
relief
the longer inflation stays High The more
stress piles up on Aaron McCullough a
single mother of three young children
everything that you bring in and that
you work harder it just seems that the
world gets a little bit harder and makes
it harder for some of that to go in your
pocket to keep from drowning in debt
McCullough shops around she works two
jobs and she goes without any anything
really movies meals um
things going out maybe going away to a
hotel for a weekend or
the summer vacations are pretty local
now a compounding impact that's being
felt everywhere foreign
Scotia is Distributing a million dollars
worth of food every month to its
Community Food Banks more than it's ever
needed to before pasta
um we got rolled oats peanut butter what
worries me is not only that we have more
people going hungry more people needing
food but it's also the mental Wellness
or frankly the lack of it that runs in
parallel with these Trends year over
year food prices increased in September
to more than 11 percent the fastest
escalation in 41 years analysts who
blamed everything from pandemic related
supply chain problems to so-called greed
inflation say another factor is emerging
the Canadian dollars low exchange rate
when you look at the list of items that
have actually gone up by more than two
percent in the last month those items
are most commonly imported from abroad
and and when they're important of course
they have to negotiating American
dollars to try to cool and inflation the
Bank of Canada is widely expected to
keep increasing interest rates but some
economists suggest an erratic Global
energy Market could drive fuel prices
even higher some say a recession is not
just possible it's almost a given
there's a lot of uncertainty over the
Outlook we think the recession can be
mild it's not it's not necessarily going
to be a dark and ugly one just yet but I
think going forward and we have to be
very careful for Aaron McCullough it's
easier said than done up everything is
up everything the pressure is still on
and it's anyone's guess when relief will
arrive
Ross Lord Global News Halifax
consumer prices are also also biking
overseas with Britain seeing a
King aflation hit a 40-year high in
September they think large part to
Soaring food prices compared to last
year the cost of food has jumped a
whopping 14.6 percent in the UK that's
the biggest rise since 1980. that's
helped push the inflation rate to 10.1
percent the new numbers helping fuel
further speculation the days are
numbered for embattled prime minister
Liz Truss
Mr Speaker the only mandate she's ever
had is from Members opposite it was a
mandate built on fantasy economics and
it ended in disaster the country's got
nothing to show for it except the
destruction of the economy and the
implosion of the Tory party Mr Speaker
[Applause]
I have acted in the National interest to
make sure that we have economic
stability
adding to her government's instability
news today that senior Tori MP sueella
Braverman has been forced to resign as
Home Secretary just weeks into the role
over what's being described as a
security breach
we are learning more tonight about the
Fatal stabbing of an RCMP officer in
British Columbia Constable Shay Len Yang
died following an altercation with a man
who was living in a tent set up in a
Burnaby Park a memorial for the Fallen
officer is growing outside the Burnaby
RCMP Detachment where she had worked for
just three years investigators now say
the suspect was shot with Constable
Yang's gun Global's Grace key is
following the story for us in Burnaby
tonight Grace
I'm at Broadview Park where the stabbing
occurred new details are emerging the
name of the suspect has now been
released he is John Wong ham and he has
been charged with first degree murder in
the Fatal stabbing of constable shailin
yang this all unfolded shortly after 11
yesterday morning Constable Yang was
with the city of Burnaby worker
responding to a homeless tent at the
park neighbors say the small tent has
been here for several months at some
point she was stabbed and she did fire
her weapon at the suspect the Constable
was rushed to a hospital where she later
died of her injuries the BC police
watched on group The Independent
investigations office has obtained video
from a nearby building of the entire
incident that is no under review at this
point in time
certain of the number of shots that were
fired
it's our information that she fired a
shot at least at the individual who was
involved and and that that person a male
went to hospital with injuries but is
expected to survive she was
compassionate and caring and she brought
those skills every day to her job
working with her community's most
vulnerable including those experiencing
homelessness and mental health issues
there was
a person to remember Constable Yang it
stretched on for six minutes it included
police cars and other emergency vehicles
Constable Yang was 31 years old she had
worked with the homeless and mental
health Outreach team she had been with
the Burnaby Detachment for just three
years nitu Grace Key in Burnaby BC
thanks
today the commission reviewing the
federal government's use of the
emergencies act in Ottawa in February
heard from Diane Deans at the time of
the freedom Convoy arriving in the
nation's capital Deans was the chair of
the city's Police Services Board she
lost that post in a political battle
with the mayor Jim Watson in her
testimony she stressed that the local
police force needed help
I definitely had the impression that
um
we
we didn't have the resources to bring
about an end to this occupation
Deans also testified the former Ottawa
Police Chief dismissed her concerns and
told her he believed the protesters
would leave after a few days the federal
government says one of the
justifications for invoking the
emergencies Act was to respond to
requests from law enforcement for more
personnel and more resources
to the war in Ukraine Russian President
Putin has declared martial law in four
regions of Ukraine that were illegally
annexed last month
the move gives more power to Regional
Governors and law enforcement in kerson
zappariza Donetsk and luhansk it also
opens the door for sweeping new
restrictions including curfews property
seizure and forced relocations people in
kerson are already on the Move Putin
says it's to ensure their protection as
Ukrainian troops ramp up their fight to
reclaim occupied territory kerson's
location makes it a pivotal Battlefield
in the conflict and as Crystal gemancing
Reports Russia is struggling to counter
key Ukrainian advances
exactly what Russian officials have told
these people we can't say for sure
Kirsten has effectively been operating
under Russian rules since being seized
early on in The Invasion
Kremlin installed leadership says
civilians have all accepted offers to be
moved to safety before Ukrainian forces
arrive
we have here two cues of people who have
applied through the call center The
People's Front plans to relocate up to
60 thousand people from the illegally
annexed territory to Crimea or Russia
Mass deportations have been used by
Russia previously in this war Ukraine
claims people are misled often ending up
in filtration camps or missing music
a round cures on the situation on the
ground was called difficult Tuesday by
one Russian military official Russian
forces are training here preparing to
fight Ukrainian troops moving south and
reclaiming territory
meanwhile Russia continues to hammer
critical infrastructure in Ukraine
in a video message the governor of Ivano
Frances explains that a key thermal
plant was hit and that residents would
need to conserve energy
President Vladimir zielinski met with
his team in Kiev in hopes of finding
ways to secure power stations while
preparing for the possibility of the
grid being totally disabled just like it
did back in February International
partners are being asked to help close
the sky over Ukraine at least three loud
explosions were reported in the capital
the Air Force says it shot down four
missiles and 10 drones the same deadly
iranian-made devices that wreaked havoc
in the country earlier this week
Crystal commencing Global News London
the Iranian rock climber who made
International headlines after competing
in South Korea without wearing a hijab
was given a hero's welcome by a cheering
crowd at tehran's airport
[Applause]
in the days following the competition no
one knew where the 33 year old athlete
was triggering fears she had been
disappeared by the Iranian regime at the
airport she said she is in good health
and publicly apologized for causing
quote turbulence and worry for the
people of Iran in a state television
statement at the airport which many
believe may have been made under duress
ruckabee said in the stress of
competition she forgot to put on her
hijab an Instagram post on her account
previously said her hijab had fallen off
a little more than seven years away and
many tons of emissions to go coming up
the prime minister's pledge to meet a
major climate goal
the Insurance Bureau of Canada says
post-tropical storm Fiona was the most
costly extreme weather event ever
recorded on the East Coast the
destruction is still being tallied but
an initial estimate suggests the cost
tops 660 million dollars in insured
damage many of the people affected by
the storm were in high risk areas where
residential flood insurance isn't
available the storm made landfall in
Nova Scotia on September 24th but caused
damage across much of Atlantic Canada
prime minister Justin Trudeau says
Canada will meet its 2030 admissions
goal in fact he's guaranteed it it's a
bold statement considering Canada has
not come close to meeting any of the
previous six emission targets that have
come and gone Trudeau says the
difference now is a robust road map to
get there Eric Sorensen reports
for decades successive Canadian
governments have failed to meet Canada's
emissions Targets this year the Trudeau
government produced a budget to reach
its targets when asked for guarantees at
a climate Forum Trudeau didn't blink can
you guarantee this time will be
different yes
wonderful yes because every other plan
was faced on targets
any politician could put forward a
Target instead of targets the
government's plan budgets nine billion
dollars in new climate Investments with
incentives for homes buildings electric
vehicles the Cornerstone is the price on
carbon to rise 170 a ton by 2030. the
Parliamentary budget office says that
will eventually cost households though
rebate checks will cover much of it in
question period conservatives assailed
carbon pricing as a cause of inflation
and deficits and this prime minister's
carbon tax is causing unjust inflation
will this prime minister stop punishing
Canadians and cancel his plans to triple
triple triple the tax on groceries gas
and Home Heating the conservative leader
has been blunt promising to scrap carbon
pricing in favor of technology to
address climate change
government will make life more
affordable by eliminating the federal
carbon tax a new report from clean
Prosperity suggests industry uncertainty
is holding back progress the possibility
a future government could roll back
carbon pricing undermines the economic
case for big investments in emissions
reductions the emissions accountability
act aims to hold governments accountable
for reductions but if there's a change
of government
unfortunately there was one party that
voted against this legislation and it
would be truly disgraceful for a new
government to come in place and not
respect the obligations under this law
the prime minister is standing behind
carbon pricing as the carbon price
increases to give predictability signals
to businesses to continue to invest in
reducing their emissions and while it's
not possible to guarantee that climate
targets eight years from now will be met
there was no attempt to soften that
guarantee either
well the latest admission Target isn't
going to need to be walked back again we
know exactly how we're going to make
those reductions is it going to be easy
no but is there a plan as to how we're
actually going to make that progress yes
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
ahead condo chaos why some Quebec
families are about to lose their homes
[Music]
for most Canadians buying a home is the
biggest investment they'll make in their
lifetime but a group of condo owners in
Quebec may be losing that investment
through no fault of their own when the
condos were built three decades ago the
contractor cut corners and now the
structure is no longer safe as Mike
Armstrong explains dozens of families
are facing bankruptcy it started with
just normal Renaissance normal
renovation we had to look at these
columns it was supposed to be just some
regular repairs Philippines mother's
Condo building and two others needed
work done to fix brick pillars and
solidify balconies the condo
associations called in a contractor and
that's when the nightmare began the
structure of the building is on the
verge of collapsing so I had to remove
my mother from the apartment
now these are videos made by Engineers
after the contractor said he wouldn't
touch the building it was too dangerous
between water infiltration and termites
parts of the three buildings were just
disintegrated the outside walls were all
rotten include beves building emergency
beams were put in just to stabilize the
structure rot was just one of the issues
the engineers also found the Builder had
cut Corners the wall studs were too far
apart and instead of lighter concrete
for the floors he'd used heavier regular
concrete well that's a good The Recipe
for Disaster the walls aren't as solid
as they should be and the ceilings and
floors are heavier than they should yeah
that's not the combination you want no
it's a pretty dangerous to live here now
the other problem is the price tag
according to Architects repairing the
three buildings would cost each owner
between 200 and 260 thousand dollars the
repair bill is more than the value of
the condo we'll lose everything you know
Lori favron paid 190 000 for her condo
she's already shelled out 32 000 for
repairs engineers and Architects and
doesn't know what happens next I'm faced
with possibly going bankrupts
the owners argue the city and the
province bear some responsibility both
issued permits but don't seem to have
inspected properly that doesn't surprise
Peter Elliott he's a private home
inspector and estimates less than 10
percent of new construction is ever
checked there's no will to it nor I
believe is there a budget for it in the
government
the original Builder went out of
business 18 years ago so there doesn't
appear to be any recourse there people
are scared without help Beltran says
about 80 percent of the owners will go
bankrupt and in the middle of a housing
crisis find themselves without a place
to live like Armstrong Global News St
Jerome Quebec
another giant leap in history next the
woman who brought indigenous Pride to
the Stars
[Music]
two giant pandas have arrived at their
new home in Qatar ahead of the World Cup
the pandas are a gift from China the
first ones to leave that country since
the pandemic 800 kilograms of fresh
bamboo will be flown in each week for
the pandas to eat
a few weeks ago Colonel Nicole Mann took
off into history as the first indigenous
woman to go to space a member of the
wylaki of the Round Valley Indian tribes
in California the astronaut is also a
former U.S marine test pilot and today
she took questions from the
International Space Station as her out
of this world achievements Inspire
indigenous women and girls around the
world here's Heather urac's West
this is Nicole Mann on board the
International Space Station I have you
loud and clear it's been two weeks since
Colonel Nicole Mann made history
blasting off as commander of NASA's
SpaceX crew 5 Mission to the
International Space Station becoming the
first indigenous woman in space I feel
very proud to be on aboard the space
station and certainly to represent
Native Americans and Indigenous people
on board for the first stage men says
seeing Earth from space has been a
deeply emotional experience and it's
difficult not to stay in the cupola all
day and just see our planet Earth and
how beautiful she is and how delicate
and fragile she is but seeing Colonel
Mann in space has been incredibly
meaningful too we even have some
questions from school children
especially for indigenous young people
like the students of this High School
science class on the sixth sick of First
Nation near Calgary it was very
inspiring
because like it's not it's not like
every day where you see um indigenous
people doing a whole bunch of like out
of this world kind of stuff she's a role
model for all indigenous uh women that
want to go into science Grace Cardinal
Garden is an indigenous environmental
science student at Trent University with
space dreams of her own people kind of
look over you
um most of the time but I think that
there are a lot of people that are a lot
of indigenous women specifically that
are starting to go into the sciences and
kind of starting to I guess prove a
point that we can also go into those
fields enter them and Excel bringing to
these complex disciplines the benefits
of an indigenous two-wide lens they are
able to use their traditional cultural
knowledge as a lens to view the world
but also being able to see the world
from a western perspective a perspective
Colonel man has now brought to space
please know that I carry your hopes and
your dreams with me to the International
Space Station the first Native American
woman a place for indigenous women
that's no longer a foreign Frontier
Heather your ex West Global News Calgary
and we're not done with Cosmic wonders
we'll leave you with a bold New
Perspective of one of them this image of
The Pillars of Creation part of a
vibrant nebula 6 500 light years away
was first captured by NASA's Hubble
telescope in 1995. it later got a bit of
a glow up in 2014 and today NASA shared
another look from its more advanced
James Webb Telescope and the results are
beyond words that is global national for
this Wednesday thanks for watching Donna
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]